have to go and rest my fare back here
comes some more breakfast
I mean prop hunt for you nail that intro
Felix come here I have a mission for you
come here come back to the stop you
don't don't talk to her like that
hey boy [ __ ] you take them you can't
tell me what to do I'm gonna take the
side of a team take both of them take
take my ass
where don't even want it Oh what
processing that Senate set surrounding
you were like a bad take it let's go
take it
if you are all right I'm going I might
just use the paper we were throwing
around my is shooting all the time
just try and ninja made of paper okay
wait can we can we grab that wait where
are you Oh for [ __ ] sake can you guess
what I am
is that you [ __ ] hey could you push a
chair over to me no push it over oh I
can do that
wait don't have seven second check it
[Music]
[Laughter]
no I'm not [ __ ] see this man walk
around dude I'll do two I'm stuck okay
come here come here come here connects
me not like dad you're in the wrong way
no face is there are ways well though no
you are no you are you are
my thing's frozen is a Swiss TV okay I'm
on the I'm on the other side of you what
why you're in the wrong way I'm just
telling you you are as well you're
facing this way you're facing like that
way to me welcome back syndicate
syndicate khmer khmer khmer this is me
this is me wait help me push something
to me TV stranger scared oh no you ain't
going anyway [ __ ]
what okay
which one hello inspector boots
[Laughter]
[Music]
no I don't want to be this [ __ ] thing
yeah we are we are not in the shed
yeah I kid around inside it all right
put this door right now
never never you're not allowed in this
motley let's blow it up
wait we can open the door we go through
the wall you'll never get us oh yeah
yeah see it's a great plan PT that was a
good play that was a good plan once a
minute bed there's one too many beds I'm
stuck
Tom money is to save yourself Tom
seriously
if you have something good to say I'll
spare your life
you ain't no chair [ __ ] I know it's
Aaron Murphy one I was sadly I was born
Abed but I tried to be the best armchair
I could ever be block off the drinks are
you doing MELAS internal with bins and
we like God on the in no I don't want to
be this peat pile of crap oh [ __ ]
we're so far
okay it's okay
says they come in come in like this
actually cuz like oh [ __ ] oh this room
is interesting I don't not inside yeah
where are you Oh where'd you go
I'm just trying to look outside for him
just in case I could well the [ __ ]
they stay freaking out about
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay the bottom so do
you come here after my favorite favorite
spot
hope you enjoy the prop hunt Maybank if
you do let me know if you want more hit
subscribe to become a bread today able
to you're not already for some reason
and say awesome love you
[Music]